[Musique]
je
berlin est 16 octobre 2009 le neues
museum qui vient d'être restaurée
réouvre ses portes
c'est ici que l'on peut admirer la plus
belle collection d'oeuvres égyptienne
d'allemagne mais le véritable événement
c'est l'arrivée d'une des reines les
plus célèbres de l'histoire d'égypte le
buste de néfertiti
[Musique]
un chef d'oeuvre qui était exposé depuis
20 ans dans le vieux musée de berlin
aujourd'hui néfertiti change l'adresse
pour venir trôner au neues museum
[Musique]
je crois que c'est un chef-d'oeuvre
absolu et en plus un chef d'oeuvre
intemporel
quelle impression de perfection de
plénitude esthétique en fait hein on
voit une beauté parfaite
d'où est ce que ça vient gâcher son
histoire qui en a fait une star 10 savez
c'est un peu comme votre mona lisa c'est
l'icône de l'identité égyptienne
néfertiti âgés de plus de 3000 ans
toutes les précautions sont prises pour
ne pas égratigner ce visage vierge de
tout défaut son état de conservation est
d'ailleurs une des plus grandes énigmes
dans l'histoire des découvertes
archéologiques
[Musique]
mais la fête est gâchée par un scandale
venant de genève est relayée par la
presse française
le buste de néfertiti est accusé d'être
un faux à l'origine de cette polémique
une enquête menée pendant plus de vingt
ans par l'historien henri stierlin sur
le fait que ce soit une copie info un
modèle une maquette joel pour moi y'a
aucun doute ce qui a d'abord éveiller
les soupçons de l'historien c'est l'état
de conservation exceptionnel dans lequel
le buste de néfertiti a été trouvé cet
objet était tellement incongru quelque
chose qui était complètement différent
de ce qu'on attendait de la part d'un
buste égyptien qui datait de 3300 ans
pour l'historien henri stierlin le buste
de néfertiti et donc bien conservé trop
peut-être trop neuf pour être vrai et
puis il ya cette autre buste trouvait à
côté de celui de néfertiti il s'agit du
buste du pharaon akhenaton son mari
totalement défiguré
comment expliquer que ces deux bustes
trouvait au même endroit et au même
moment soit dans un état de conservation
si différents alors le buste de
néfertiti serait-il info à montpellier
l'archéologue égyptologue marc gabolde
spécialiste de néfertiti répond aux
accusations d' henri stierlin il faut se
dire qu'il ait eu raison de poser la
question que les arguments qu'il a
fournies ne sont pas suffisants si on
arrive à me donner des arguments
scientifiques fort comme quoi cette info
je me résoudrai restera toujours une
petite un petit élément de doute on se
la met
retour dans les sous sols du nejm muséum
où est organisée une conférence de
presse les journalistes invités prennent
des notes
mais aucune question sur les accusations
à propos de l'authenticité du buste
car remettre en cause le buste de
néfertiti outre-rhin est tabou car ce
buste découvert par l'archéologue
allemand ludwig borchardt
il y a près d'un siècle en egypte est
devenu un symbole en allemagne nous
avons néanmoins posé la question à
madame zai fried directrice du noise
music
quand on est devant ce juste on ne se
pose pas la question et astiz que ce bus
est authentique va de soi on devrait
plutôt se poser la question pourquoi
serait il faut de nombreux archéologues
français italiens américains émettent
des doutes sur l'authenticité de ce
buste aucun n'a souhaité nous répondre
officiellement nous avons donc décidé de
mener notre propre enquête
vous verrez que tout le monde se tient
par la barbichette et que personne n'ose
se mouiller dans ses opérations pour
déclarer que l'objet est véritablement
un show
alors le buste le plus célèbre de
l'histoire de l'égypte est il un faux
nous avons rencontré les plus grands
experts sur la question soumis le bus au
détecteur de mensonges remonter le cours
de l'histoire
ce que nous avons découvert dans cette
enquête changera à jamais votre regard
sur la plus mystérieuse reine d'égypte
et sa représentation
le buste de néfertiti
[Musique]
qui était néfertiti voilà un des plus
grands mystères de l'histoire
pharaonique de l'egypte des générations
d'archéologues on fouille est derrière
tous les monuments décrypter jacques
hiéroglyphes gravés sur les pylônes et
les murs des temples pour tenter de
traquer le moindre indice évoquant son
existence
pour retrouver les premières traces de
la reine néfertiti les archéologues ont
remonté le cours du nil jusqu'à carnac
dans un des centres religieux les plus
importants d'égypte c'est dans ce
labyrinthe de temples et de colonnes que
l'on a enfin trouvé la première image de
la reine néfertiti une image gravée
délicatement sur une pierre ayant
appartenu un temple disparu mais des
origines de néfertiti on ne sait rien
probablement égyptienne mais surtout
première épouse du célèbre pharaon de la
xviiième dynastie legrand akhenaton
[Musique]
néfertiti et l épouse principal
d'akhenaton c'était la seule femme qui
était en droit de porter le titre de
grande épouse du roi
on connaît les soeurs de la reine et on
connaît sa nourrice mais de l'origine de
la famille de néfertiti on ne sait rien
la niche si je veux être honnête je dois
vous dire on ne sait pas c'est la reine
d'egypte dont on possède le plus de
représentation le plus de documents
qu'ils évoquent
et c'est peut être une de celles dont on
sait le moins on ne connaît pas les
parents de néfertiti mais ce qui nous
frappe c'est sa beauté unique avec ce
visage qui nous paraît au premier regard
si moderne si l'on connaît le nom de la
reine néfertiti c'est grâce à son époux
akhenaton le rebelle l'hérétique car ce
pharaon s'est rendu célèbre en faisant
table rase de tous les dieux égyptiens
pour imposer un seul dieu
hatton le dieu soleil
sous son règne pendant la xviiie
dynastie akhenaton construit de nouveaux
temples à ciel ouvert pour permettre aux
rayons de l'astre solaire de diffuser
leurs bienfaits dans sa nouvelle
religion le pharaon akhenaton développe
le culte de la personnalité
car désormais akhenaton est le dieu
soleil ne font qu'un
néfertiti et akhenaton ont également
formé le couple le plus romantique de
toutes les dynasties pharaoniques leur
amour l'un pour l'autre a débuté très
tôt sur cette statue r ils sont âgés d'à
peine 14 ans le peuple découvre pour la
première fois deux adolescents mètres
d'un empire se tenant par la main dans
les représentations ils sont très
amoureux l'un de l'autre
ce que l'on voit le tout à fait étonnant
c'est le roi des arènes s'embrasser
ils sont sur le chat royal et akena
t'embrasse néfertiti néfertiti est en
train de poser un collier au cou
d'akhenaton et elle en profite pour lui
voler un petit baiser au passage donc on
a une très très grande intimité qui est
représentée qui est certainement le
reflet d'un grand amour akhenaton et
néfertiti quittent la région de carnac
pour venir s'installer au centre de
l'egypte at-elle el-amarna au milieu
d'un désert
c'est là qu'ils construisent une
nouvelle cité royale qui l'ont baptisé
ac est atone
l'horizon du soleil le plus célèbre
couple de l'histoire d'egypte tu vas
vivre dans une ville moderne construite
rapidement pouvant accueillir 50 mille
habitants une cité doté de nombreux
temples sans toi car akhenaton et
néfertiti consacre la majorité de leur
temps à l'adoration du dieu soleil
mais le règne d'akhenaton et de
néfertiti ne durera que 17 ans après
leur mort
leurs successeurs effaceront toute trace
de leur existence et démontrons les
palais pierre par pierre
en moins d'une trentaine d'années la
cité se videra de ses habitants et
redeviendra un désert
c'est un petit peu mon pays des sables
et quand on foule
les bâtiments qui datent de la xviiie
dynastie on n'a qu'un niveau
d'occupation en quelque sorte celui de
l'époque d'akhenaton et c'est une ville
qui a vécu en gros une quinzaine
d'années c'est ce qui est très peu on a
un instantané de la vie égyptienne
c'est dans ce désert de 10 km de long
sur 5 km de large que le 6 décembre 1912
le buste de néfertiti surgit intacte au
milieu de nulle part
ce bus de tailler dans le calcaire
émergent sous 50 centimètres de gravats
borchardt ressuscite une reine intacte
presque vivante avec toutes ses couleurs
mythe comment l'archéologue borchardt
aurait-il fait jaillir ce chef-d'oeuvre
au milieu de nulle part avant l'arrivée
de l'allemand
l'ancien site et d'akena tonnes était la
chasse gardée des anglais et de leurs
chefs
archéologue flight nurse pétri lui ses
équipes en 1891 et 1892 avait déjà
fouillé partout
ils avaient tous vers les tombeaux
découvert les magnifiques fresques des
hauts dignitaires mise à jour les
fondations des palais mais jamais ils
n'ont découvert un chef-d'oeuvre
comme cette néfertiti l'arrivée de
l'archéologue allemand borchardt en 1906
fait sourire les anglais ils ricanent
même ils sont persuadés que l'allemand
fera chou blanc peut tuer était déjà là
il arrêtait les fouilles à tell el
amarna à la fin du 19e siècle
pour lui c'était fini ils étaient sûrs
qu'il n'y avait plus rien à trouver mais
de ce que l'on sait c'est ne fut pas le
cas
c'est ce match leur charte arriva à
marnaz et les chalets parce qu'il
s'intéressait à l'urbanisme égyptiens au
maillot jaune on domestique manque et un
coeur mais il avait un autre plan il
était en contact avec le musée de berlin
il voulait ramener quelque chose de
spectaculaire à berlin ring back to
baleine
en ce début de xxème siècle l'egypte est
le plus grand terrain de chasse pour les
archéologues du monde entier dans cette
course au trésor
la prusse est en retard guillaume de
charges alors borchardt de ramener un
trophée à tout prix avant de commencer
ces fouilles l'archéologue malins se
renseigne auprès des antiquaires du
vieux caire qui trafiquent avec les
pilleurs c'est là qu'il apprend qu'une
partie de la cité d'akena tonnes n'a pas
été encore fouillés
porsche halte est aussi un architecte
alors dès son arrivée il aurait établi
un plan de la zone sud est celle du
quartier des artisans
là où ni les anglais ni les pilleurs ne
sont allé gratter
et s'intéresse à l'habitat donc il va
fouiller d'abord les grandes villas qui
se distingue sur le site parce que
forment un petit monticule
et puis il va étendre ces fouilles à
l'habitat un petit peu plus commun et
par extraordinaire il va tomber à un
moment donné sur l'officine et la villa
du sculpteur touthmôsis qui va être le
point d'orgue de ces fous grâce à sa
méthode borchardt identifie rapidement
une propriété composée de plusieurs
ateliers de sculpteur
excité l'archéologue visite le jardin et
ratissent le moindre centimètre carré
c'est là qu'ils identifient derrière ces
silos une maison qui aurait appartenu
aux chefs des sculpteurs d'akhenaton et
néfertiti
c'est dans cette maison que borchardt
aurait découvert le buste de néfertiti
intrigué par ce miracle nous avons voulu
retourner un siècle plus tard sur les
traces de l'archéologue ludwig borchardt
retrouver la maison dans laquelle le
buste a été découvert direction le sud à
cinq heures de route du caire où se
trouve-t-elle el amarna la cité fantôme
d'akena tonnes est de néfertiti nous
sommes accompagnés de luxe watrin
archéologues chasseurs de faux et expert
en objets d'art de l'egypte antique
auprès des tribunaux et de l'archéologue
égyptien
hamada inspecteur général du chantier de
fouilles de tell el amarna ou là le
rapport de borchardt sur le buste de
néfertiti
c'est un vieux quand ces messieurs
official report m'adapter
luc watrin a emporté avec lui un
document exceptionnel
les notes et les croquis de
l'archéologue ludwig borchardt dans
lesquelles il raconte tout de sa
découverte du buste en 1912
ce document va nous aider à retrouver
l'endroit exact où le buste de néfertiti
aurait été découvert
voilà ce qu'il reste trois mille trois
cents ans plus tard de l'atelier du chef
sculpteur touthmôsis c'est quelque part
dans une de ses pièces qu borchardt
l'archéologue allemand aurait découvert
le buste de néfertiti plan en main
l'archéologue luc watrin décrypte les
lieux alors là effectivement c'est
émouvant
vous avez la salle de réception du
propriétaire de la villa c'est très
certainement ici que ses hôtes de marque
venaient mais également pourquoi pas
venez poser les hauts personnages de
l'état et pourquoi pas la reine
néfertiti elle même alors quitte la
salle de la réception est là bien
évidemment on arrive sur l'atelier du
sculpteur derrière la porte bord de
chars des traits précis dans ses écrits
qu'est ce qu'ils découvrent dans cet
angle ici le buste de la reine
d'après borchardt néfertiti et elle a
enfoui depuis trois mille deux cents ans
et pourtant si vivante et ce n'est pas
fini
la maison du chef des sculpteurs
d'akhenaton regorge de trésors borchardt
découvre dans les autres pièces la plus
belle collection de bustes de l'époque
d' akhenaton des masques de plâtre à
l'aspect étrangement réaliste des
modèles d'ateliers comme celui
d'akhenaton lui même un modèle et nash
20 et le fameux buste défiguré du
pharaon akhenaton trouvait juste à côté
de celui de néfertiti ludwig borchardt
offre ainsi au musée de berlin c'est
plus beau trophée
mais dans ce conte de fées bros
archéologues un détail va retenir
l'attention d'un historien
un élément qui va déclencher une enquête
digne d'un roman policier
[Musique]
au caire dans sa maison coloniale
l'archéologue ludwig borchardt mettra
étrangement plus d'une dizaine d'années
pour livrer un rapport complet sur ces
fouilles de tell el amarna de 1912 il y
relate l'histoire de la découverte du
buste en calcaire de néfertiti et de
celle d'un autre piste lui aussi en
calcaire trouvait juste à côté
le buste du pharaon akhenaton au visage
éclaté dans ses relevés topographiques
borchardt a soigneusement noté
l'emplacement du buste de néfertiti mais
il a également dessiné l'emplacement du
fameux buste des figures et d'akena
tonnes d'après les plans de
l'archéologue le buste de néfertiti
était posé sur une étagère dans l'angle
de l'atelier 7 au sol à l'entrée à
gauche que borchardt découvre d'abord le
buste d'akena tonnes
puis le temps fait son ouvrage le mur
extérieur se serait effondrée et le
buste de néfertiti avec akhenaton est
retrouvé en plusieurs morceaux
alors que néfertiti juste à côté est
intacte comme si elle venait de sortir
de l'atelier du sculpteur
étrange cette histoire ne serait qu'une
supercherie une imposture de borchardt
c'est ce qu'affirme l'historien suisse
henri stierlin qui a enquêté pendant
plus de 20 ans il remet en question le
rapport de borchardt
il accuse tout simplement néfertiti
d'être trop belle pour être authentique
comment est ce qu'il est possible qu'un
objet aussi lourd aussi délicat avec une
peinture absolument intacts puisse
tomber comme borchardt suppose d'un
rayonnage qui est à peu près 1 mètre 50
du sol dans des éboulis dans des
cailloutis sans s'abîmer
surtout que il indique que l'objet est
tombé face contre terre
et puis il se dit que c'est comme un
objet tellement délicat que c'est pas
possible que les seuls éléments qui ont
été abîmés c'est les oreilles pour les
oreilles et n'entrent pas en contact
brutal avec le sol quand l'objet tombe
au début de l'enquêté en 1984 henri
stierlin confie c'est tout à dietrich
building un des plus grands égyptologue
allemand hors de tout soupçon
à l'époque il est directeur du musée de
munich il a étudié le bus pendant de
longues années les donne raison et
encourage même henri stierlin dans une
lettre
je suis tenu de recevoir une lettre qui
me dit votre projet tout à fait
concluant il est convaincant il le dit
dans une lettre qu'il m'envoyait où il
dit c'est lucie ou du beurre zeigen ce
jeu lucic convaincant cohérent
dans ce courrier dietrich ville donc
confirme également que lui aussi a des
doutes sur l'étrange état de
conservation de néfertiti que son style
ne correspond pas à celui de l'époque d'
akhenaton et qu'il est même prêt à faire
la préface de son enquête
puis en 1989 il est nommé conservateur
du buste de néfertiti ait fait volte
face et puis subitement ville d'ogm
envoie une autre lettre où il annonce
qu'il est nos murs comme directeur du
musée de berlin est évidemment berlin
c'est la ville où est conservé le buste
de néfertiti et tout le problème se
repose d'une manière complètement
différente pour lui il me dit qu'il est
obligé de prendre ses distances avec le
projet une peu plus engagé mais en plus
chose qui ne semble déjà plus
inquiétante
ils m'envoient deux émissaires de berlin
du musée de berlin qui sont tous les
deux des égyptologues deux émissaires
qui sont chargés de me dissuader de
continuer le marcheix rhj mais
l'historien henri stierlin n'est pas un
homme à se laisser impressionner
il va enquêter sans relâche mais
désormais seul contre tous intrigué par
cette histoire nous retournons à berlin
pour un rendez vous programmé avec
dietrich building
la veille de notre rencontre l'expert
archéologues annuler l'interview nous le
rappelons feignant de ne pas avoir reçu
son message
[Musique]
allô oui monsieur dietrich ville donc je
vous appelle parce que nous avons rendez
vous demain pour une interview au sujet
de néfertiti je voulais savoir à quelle
heure on se retrouvait on apprendra plus
tard que les autorités allemandes ont
interdit formellement monsieur ville
d'ong de communiquer sur le buste de
néfertiti
et d'évoquer l'enquète henri stierlin
pour l'historien le buste de la reine
serait le fruit d'une expérience
borchardt aurait fait fabriquer une
copie du buste de néfertiti leur charte
voulait étudier la technique de la
sculpture sur plâtre et surtout la façon
dont les égyptiens utilisaient la
couleur et pour cela borchardt aurais-tu
à sa disposition des matériaux trouvés
sur place dans les fouilles de tell el
amarna
bientôt sur place j'avais le plâtre
c'est pas compliqué à faire c'est un
datable et puis la pierre qui est au
centre
c'est pas ce qui manque en egypte et
pierre envoyer c'est vraiment le pays de
l'est lui du calcaire ressort gros blocs
de calcaire sont les pauvres pour juste
qu'ils prennent à peu près la forme de
la statue qu'on va faire et puis on met
du plâtre et là le sculpteur entre en
action et fait véritablement une copie
des visages qu'ils avaient en grande
quantité dans les découvertes qui avait
été faite des objets authentiques comme
ce buste un authentique modèle de
néfertiti inachevé trouvaient également
dans l'atelier de tout metz le sculpteur
d'akena tonnes sur celui ci on remarque
des traces de charbon elle indique les
parties restantes à sculpter borchardt
aurait-il utilisé un modèle comme celui
ci trouvait sur place et qui aurait
ensuite été colorée
borchardt qui le dis très clairement
dans ses carnets de fouilles avaient
découvert des pigments ou une grande
quantité nous le dit et qui sont prêtes
à l'emploi
mais alors s'il s'agissait d'une copie
expérimental comment expliquer que
borchardt n'en ai jamais parlé à son
entourage ou dans son rapport de
fouilles
d'après l'historien le 5 décembre 1912
l'archéologue borchardt est au caire il
apprend qu'une des familles princières
de la future allemagne de passage en
egypte souhaitent visiter son chantier
de fouilles borchardt pris de court
rejoint tell el amarna au plus vite le
jour de son arrivée le 6 décembre 1912
devait être un jour de repos pour les
ouvriers il remet immédiatement ses
équipes au travail
puis fièrement présente aux altesse le
fruit de ses recherches
bruxelles le contremaître des fouilles
scène aussi l'égyptien s'absente un
instant et revient avec la reine
néfertiti dans les bras la famille
royale s'extasie devant le chef-d'oeuvre
un photographe immortalise l'événement
borchardt n'aurait pas eu le temps
d'expliquer aux halles thèse qu'il
s'agissait d'une copie et non d'un
authentique d'après henri stierlin cette
photo sera le piège qui se refermera sur
l'archéologue
on peut pas comme ça dira d altesse qui
sont 30 s'extasier devant un objet
écoutez vous vous trompez c'est ridicule
on ridiculise les altesses il a été tenu
de ne pas démentir
auquel cas c'était il couvre de ridicule
les altesses royales et c'était un crime
de lèse majesté qui à l'époque était
quand même quelque chose de très grave
je pouvais vraiment porter atteinte à
toute sa carrière
après la visite royale le buste va
disparaître étrangement pendant près de
onze ans borchardt
laure a confié discrètement à son mécène
j'aime ce simon c'est grâce à ce riche
industriel que l'archéologue a pu
financer une partie de ces fouilles
hateley la marne à james a reçu le
message de la découverte du buste fort
fils était très excité tout berlin
attendait le retour de la reine mais le
buste a terminé sur la commode de chez
mon arrière grand père pendant plus de
dix ans de 1912 à 1924 borchardt
refusera systématiquement d'exposer la
reine en public
moi d'abord je m'étais pas rendu compte
que l'oeil ce qui manquait était aussi
une atteinte aussi forte
son portrait à son image
néfertiti borgne un crime de lèse
majesté
un sacrilège porté à l'image pharaonique
de la grande reine d'égypte pour
vérifier cet argument nous nous rendons
à l'université de liège en belgique chez
dimitri labourie c'est un des plus
grands spécialistes de l'histoire de
l'art et de l'archéologie en egypte
pharaonique
il nous livre son expertise sur le sujet
c'est un buste d'ateliers c'est un objet
utilitaire en fait c'est un bus qui est
destiné à permettre aux sculpteurs de
reproduire de façon fidèle l'image
canonique de néfertiti telle qu'elle
était décidée par akhenaton et
probablement par néfertiti nm aussi pour
le professeur labourie ce buste comme
d'autres objets royaux était un outil de
communication la représentation
officielle de la reine néfertiti devait
être reconnaissable au premier coup
d'oeil par les prêtres
le peuple du nord au sud de l'egypte une
sorte de marianne pharaonique
quant à l'oeil borgne qui choque
l'historien henri stierlin d'après les
experts il servirait de modèle pour
indiquer la forme et la profondeur exact
qu'il faut sculptée pour ensuite
incrusté correctement les yeux de
néfertiti
pour dimitri labourie ce bus de royal
était un modèle d'ateliers typique du
style de la famille d'akena tonnes
[Musique]
si on regarde la bouche d'akhenaton si
on regarde la bouche des princesses
amarnienne si on regarde la bouche du
beau-père de néfertiti elle est traitée
avec ce même sensualiste de façon
différente mais l'esthétique même est
semblable mais l'élément déterminant en
faveur de l'authenticité du buste aurait
été démontrée par un des meilleurs
égyptologue allemand rolf cross
ce que l'on sait c'est que ce buste a
été fabriqué selon une grille de
proportions à n'importe quelle grille de
proportion mais celle du doigt égyptiens
dans leur système de mesure les anglais
ont le pied ou le pousse les égyptiens
utilisaient le doigt en référence pour
créer un nouveau buste le sculpteur
d'akena tonnes aurait dessiné au
préalable une grille de référence pour
les sculpteurs des autres régions
d'égypte chaque ligne était calculée sur
la largeur d'un doigt
le buste de néfertiti devait
correspondre à cette unité
rolls royce a mis également en évidence
que certaines intersections
correspondait systématiquement à des
points anatomy précis sur le visage
comme ceux de la base du nez ou de la
bouche
ainsi la longueur du visage de la reine
est calibré de la base du menton à celle
de la coiffe
elle est construite suivant une grille
de proportions calculé en unité de
mesure égyptienne 1,875 cm le doigt
égyptien ce qui fait que les métriques
mans construite et il aurait fallu que
le faux soeur sacha l'époque qu'il
fallait utiliser le cm égyptien et non
le cm actuelle cette grille de
proportions aurait permis de
standardiser la fabrication du buste de
néfertiti dans toute l'egypte
apparemment les faussaires du début du
19e siècle ignorait cette particularité
mais il ya une autre anomalie qui fait
dire à l'historien que ce buste est une
aberration les épaules coupé
verticalement les bas de ce buste été
coupé à la verticale or à quelques très
rares exceptions près c'est une formule
qui n'existe pas dans l'art égyptien
les bus sont coupés horizontalement à la
hauteur des épaules et non pas
verticalement
le buste de néfertiti aux épaules coupé
verticalement serait-il un cas unique
dans l'histoire de l'egypte pour en
savoir plus nous retournons cette fois à
berlin
ounaïs museum sa directrice madame
hybrid nous affirme qu'il existe un
autre exemplaire de bustes aux épaules
coupé verticalement
ce buste trouvé par borchardt dans ces
fouilles de 1912 fait partie d'une série
d'objets jamais exposés en public
irrité par le scandale du livre d' henri
stierlin madame fried à remuer toutes
les archives de la réserve pour
ressortir ce fameux buste ou plutôt ce
qu'il en reste
oui c'est possible de montrer d'autres
buste avec des épaules coupé
verticalement
celui ci par exemple vient des fouilles
de tell el amarna vais voir encore le
train qui signale l'axé central du buste
et vous voyez bien c est faux coupées
sont comme ceux de la gamme colorée il
existerait donc un deuxième but aux
épaules coupée dans cette bagarre
d'experts
cet argument est il suffisant pour
prouver définitivement l'authenticité de
la reine néfertiti retour sur berlin
le neues museum pour tenter de mettre
fin à toutes ces rumeurs a décidé de
soumettre le buste de néfertiti au
détecteur de mensonges la science va
t'elle prouver son authenticité
le buste a été transféré à l'hôpital de
la charité de berlin pour y subir un
scanner on peut enfin voir ce que
néfertiti a dans la tête
première constatation le buste est formé
d'un noyau calcaire un noyau enrobé de
plâtre une technique qui a permis aux
sculpteurs ou aux faussaires de modifier
certaines parties du buste
ce qui signifie que néfertiti aurait été
retouchée
vous voyez très bien ici les pôles vue
de l'arrière la partie blanche
c'est la pierre calcaire est ce que vous
voyez au dessus en gris c'est du plâtre
c'est une application faite après la
sculpture c'est un rajout de plâtre pour
corriger ce que vous voyez très
clairement sur cette vue arrière c'est
que l'épaule droite et plus haute que la
gauche du plâtre pour corriger et
renforcer la courbe du coup du buste en
calcaire de néfertiti et ce n'est pas
fini
le sculpteur ou le faussaire a même
corriger les joues et les pommettes du
visage ainsi que l'arête du nez de
néfertiti en rajoutant là aussi du
plâtre le premier lifting de l'histoire
mais en dehors de cette chirurgie
plastique que prouve c'est tomographie
ou la tomographie n'est pas une preuve
au contraire on ne peut en coupant des
tranches dans l'intérieur d'un objet en
rien expliqué l'époque à laquelle cet
objet est né on peut tout simplement
dire que dans cet objet il ya un eu de
pierre le noyau de pierre et ya une
couche dans blow up qui a été sculptée
mais à quel moment on est totalement
incapable d'y répondre
on ne peut pas dire que grâce à cette
méthode
ce buste est âgé de 3300 ans reste la
couche de plâtre appliqué sur le buste
en calcaire de néfertiti se plaindre
date il de l'époque d' akhenaton les
allemands ont extrait un échantillon de
ce plâtre sur le buste de néfertiti pour
le faire analyser par un chimiste
spécialiste des objets égyptiens et les
achats dans un morceau de plâtre
on retrouve un mélange d'éléments qui
existe est uniquement à la période
amarnienne et en poivre
c'est au même titre que l'architecturé
les masques
c'est à dire que ce mélange c'est une
invention de l'époque la composition de
ce plâtre et donc typique de la période
hommes en armes
autrement dit le plâtre qui recouvre le
buste de néfertiti était bien celui qui
était utilisé par les égyptiens
il y à 3300 à l'époque de la découverte
du buste on ne pouvait pas connaître la
composition de ce plâtre parce que la
technique d'analysé permettant d'y
arriver a été mise au point uniquement
dans les années 50 un faussaire ne
pouvait donc connaître la composition de
ce plâtre reste l'éventualité qu'ils
auraient pu utiliser du plâtre trouvait
sur place en 1912 question pour
l'instant restées sans réponse reste une
dernière chance d'authentifier néfertiti
grâce à la science
les pigments qui donne cet aspect si
vivant à la reine des pigments qui imite
parfaitement la couleur de la peau les
rentes sa bouche
si sensuelle quatre couleurs dominent
l'art égyptien
le bleu le vert locre et le jaune la
technique d'utilisation et de mélange
des pigments par les artistes égyptiens
est spécifique à chaque dynastie
en analysant les pigments trouver
at-elle el amarna allons nous confirmer
l'authenticité du buste l'analyse de
piment démontrer que c'est bien des
couleurs qui ont été utilisés dans
l'antiquité égyptienne et la technique
d'utilisation de ces pigments a été
abandonné après cette période
mais là aussi le faussaire aurait pu
tricher
rappelez vous lors de la découverte de
néfertiti borchardt avait trouvé sur
place dans l'atelier de tout metz le
sculpteur un petit trésor des pigments
de toutes les couleurs
du jaune de locre tirant sur le rouge de
l'eau claire et même le fameux bleu
lapis lazuli à ce titre à la fin du
règne d'akhenaton
quand les artisans sculpteurs ont
abandonné leurs ateliers de tell el
amarna ils ont emporté les choses les
plus importantes
certainement une grande partie des
réserves de pigments mais c'est vrai ils
ont laissé quelques-uns sur place admis
reste des pigments suffisamment pour
colorer une reine alors néfertiti vraies
ou fausses
du côté des experts il n'y a aucun doute
toutes les analyses historiques et
scientifiques sont catégoriques
les matériaux sont donc authentique mais
il ya un problème
une contradiction un doute aucun des
matériaux dont elle est constituée ne
permet de lui donner un âge aucune
expertise scientifique ne permet à
l'heure actuelle de dater les sculptures
en pierre
la reine polychrome à l'éternelle
jeunesse continuera pendant de longues
années a dévié la science et comme
toutes les grandes dames de l'histoire à
cacher son âge
au début du 20e siècle les bourgeois
passionnés d'égypte jouent aux
explorateurs en suivant les traces des
archéologues
[Musique]
la découverte du buste de néfertiti par
l'archéologue ludwig borchardt a
déclenché un engouement particulier pour
les objets datant de l'époque d'
akhenaton mais hélas ils sont très rares
sur le marché
qu'à cela ne tienne les faussaires vont
se mettre au travail
au caire au début du xxème siècle un
certain emile brugger va trouver la
bonne combine il va fournir à des
artistes des oeuvres authentiques pour
les faire copier et en faire défaut rien
de plus facile pour ce petit futé à
l'époque il est responsable du magasin
des antiquités égyptiennes au musée du
caire pendant une période
le musée autorisé ses collaborateurs
donc jeu sur tous les restaurateurs à
prendre des objets chez eux pour étudier
les ans certains de ces restaurateurs
deviendront de redoutables faussaires il
ne reste aucune trace aujourd'hui de
leur identité
voici les deux seule photo connue d'un
faussaire vers 1910 celle d'un maltais
du nom de barolo dingli peintre
sculpteur il faut sert à ses heures il
exerçait son art à domicile petite
anecdote qui a son importance
ludwig borchardt le fréquentait
régulièrement une émission de borchardt
était de s'occuper des achats pour les
collections allemande de musée on dit
jean sablon à cette époque le business
des faussaires était florissant il
fallait à tout prix éviter de faire deux
mauvaises achats et les faussaires sont
nombreux à cette époque difficile
d'évaluer aujourd'hui leur production
mais néanmoins une question se pose
existe-t-il encore défaut de cette
époque exposées dans les musées n'existe
pas un musée au monde qui ne possèdent
pas de faute il faut dire que les
faussaires livrer un travail de très
grande qualité et en tant qu'expert nous
ne sommes jamais à l'abri d'acheter un
folk dans nos réserves on possède des
défauts qui pour la plupart remonte aux
années 20 cent ans plus tard la capitale
égyptienne et ses 16 millions
d'habitants
abritel encore des faussaires aussi doué
que ceux de la première génération pour
tenter de les rencontrer
nous avons pris contact avec l'un
d'entre eux
l'udc va être un archéologue et
chasseurs de phoques nous accompagne
pour rencontrer ces faussaires nous
quittons le caire pour prendre la
direction de même vis
alors on se dirigera vers memphis
l'antique memphis qui se situe à 25 km
au sud du caire où se trouve donc une
zone d'ateliers où vivent et travaillent
les plus performants des contrefacteurs
égyptien chaud dans tous les cas il faut
être prudent mais le fait de pouvoir
aussi de parler l'arabe va nous aider je
pense à instaurer une confiance assez
rapidement leur père dit faussaires dans
la banlieue du caire se situe à mithra
in est un quartier sensible
aucun touriste ne s'aventure ici pour
entrer en contact avec les faussaires
nous nous faisons passer pour de gros
acheteurs travaillant pour le compte de
collectionneurs fortunés
nous avons rendez vous avec nous dira un
jeune faussaires
[Rires]
en ce moment nous dire travaille sur du
calcaire ils nous proposent de sculpter
une petite tête de pharaon en moins de
dix minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah oui là on voit la technique c'est à
dire les points de repère le calcaire
qui l'a choisi et très tendre à l'aide
d'une simple ras moudir fini sa
démonstration en quelques minutes puis
ils trempent la sculpture dans l'eau
pour faire apparaître peu les nervures
du calcaire le résultat est convaincant
on n'ose imaginer ce que ce jeune
sculpteur pourrait faire en deux mois de
travail
d'après une oeuvre originale sur une
statue en granit où on durite d'eau
n'est figé lui amène un original et qui
peut me le refaire à la perfection
[Applaudissements]
oui je peux copier et je te le ferait
vraiment bien d'ailleurs je peux te
montrer quelque chose pour achever de
nous convaincre qu'il pourrait faire
partie de nos fournisseurs nous dire
nous montre un buste en granit rose sur
lequel il s'entraîne en ce moment et
qu'il a copié juste d'après une simple
photo
lapierre qui a utilisé vous dire est
vieille de 3000 ans de quoi tromper les
meilleurs experts
mais d'où vient elle comment est il
possible de se procurer une pierre
datant de l'époque des pharaons
la réponse se trouve à quelques
centaines de mètres de la maison de vous
dire les ruines d'un temple de l'époque
de ramsès ii en plein centre-ville de me
traîner ce site est laissé à l'abandon
sans surveillance une mine pour les
faussaires il suffit de se pencher pour
récolter des vestiges de l'egypte
antique dans quelques années ce site
sera entièrement pillés il ne restera
plus rien sinon peu défaut sculpté dans
la jambe de ramsès 2 ou dans une colonne
à lire aux glyphes qui elle par contre
sont authentiques berlin mars 2011
un an et demi après l'inauguration d'une
hes museum
des milliers de visiteurs se bousculent
pour venir rendre visite à la meilleure
ambassadrice d'égypte en allemagne la
reine néfertiti la joconde des allemands
mais de l'autre côté de la méditerranée
au caire ce nouveau succès de la star du
noise muséum a provoqué une grande
colère et réveillé des sentiments
nationalistes au fond de l'allée
centrale du grand musée du caire l'homme
le plus puissant dans le monde de
l'égyptologie nous a donné rendez vous
dans la salle dédiée au grand pharaon
akhenaton et son épouse néfertiti pour
une déclaration de guerre
pour le moment tout cela fait plus de
deux ans que nous avons enquêté jusqu'à
ce que nous ayons la preuve que le buste
de néfertiti à berlin a été emporté de
façon illégale en dehors de l'egypte le
buste de néfertiti devrait être
aujourd'hui dans ce musée n'ont pas
berlin le buste de néfertiti volés par
les allemands pourquoi zahi hawass
prononce-t-il une accusation aussi grave
au début du 20e siècle le résultat des
fouilles étaient partagés à parts égales
entre l'égypte et les archéologues
d'après zahi hawass secrétaire suprême
des antiquités en egypte ludwig
borchardt aurait triché
concernant la reine néfertiti à cette
époque il y avait une règle qui disait
que tout objet représentant un roi ou
une reine découvert à télé la marne à ne
pouvait quitter l'egypte le 17 janvier
1913 ce fameux gustave lefèvre quitte le
caire portel el amarna
les fouilles ont été arrêtés il ya déjà
un mois tous les objets découverts par
les allemands ont été répertoriés et mis
en caisse prêt à partir au musée de
berlin ludwig borchardt attendu stable
le faire l'allemand est nerveux car il
craint que lefebvre n'en porte avec lui
sa plus belle découverte
la reine néfertiti que s'est-il passé ce
soir-là nous le savons grâce au
témoignage d'un collègue de borchardt
bruno goût de bord qu il a été le témoin
de toute la scène de partage et à tout
relaté dans une lettre ou tard a dit que
les caisses étaient ouvertes
ils ont tous regardé personne n'était là
pour voir must have lefebvre a fait son
choix mais comment lefebvre at-il fait
ce choix pourquoi at il laissé le buste
de néfertiti aux allemands d'après à
göteborg le témoin du partage
borchardt aurait manoeuvré de façon très
habile il savait que le jeune gustave
lefèvre ne s'intéressait pas aux
sculptures mais était un spécialiste des
écritures anciennes
pour éviter que le faire nay fouillé dès
son arrivée dans la caisse de néfertiti
borchardt lui présente comme objet
numéro un une stèle en couleurs
représentant le couple
akhenaton néfertiti et les princesses
lefebvre se jettent dessus pour étudier
les hiéroglyphes
puis d'après le témoin de la scène pour
charte présente à lefebvre non pas les
objets de ces fouilles
mais des photos en noir et blanc des
photos de sculptures des bustes de
princesses et surtout une photo de la
reine néfertiti un portrait si
majestueux que lefebvre aurait dû
reconnaître la reine l'homme par qui le
scandale va arriver ces rôles kross
ancien conservateur du musée
égyptologiques de berlin il décide enfin
de dévoiler toute la vérité sur ce
partage il affirme que lefebvre n'a
jamais examiné le contenu des caisses
et qu'on ne lui a pas présenté la photo
de la reine néfertiti mais une autre
photo mais alors là qu'elle goûte au
rock a écrit que lefebvre a vu une
mauvaise photo de néfertiti c'est à dire
sur la photo on ne voyait qu'une partie
du buste le nez la bouche et les yeux
mais pas la totalité du butin photo
photographier des sombres pas en couleur
comme les photos d'aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que lefebvre aurait vu en photo c'est
donc une reine privé de sa coiffe royal
et de son collier ressemble en tout à
coup à une princesse mais lefebvre avait
la possibilité d'aller juger sur pièce
en sortant les objets des caisses
s'il a vécu ce réflexe il aurait
découvert le splendide buste de
néfertiti d'un nouveau de l'efm d'asmara
si on a emmené lefebvre vers les caisses
lefebvre n'a pas demandé à faire sortir
les pièces originales
il ne pouvait pas savoir un souk dans
l'une d'entre elles il y avait une si
jolie pièce pour chat a fait tout son
possible pour cacher la beauté du buste
et la sortie d'egypte illégalement aux
pilotes et les grilles
borchardt aurait-il tromper lefebvre en
lui montrant une photo tronquée de la
reine qui est évidemment pour sciences
[Musique]
oh